The first couple of Thor movies lacked a little
something — at least, when compared to the
likes of Iron Man and Captain America: The
Winter Soldier.
That all changed when director Taika Waititi
came onboard to helm Thor: Ragnarok, the third
installment of the series, and a film that
completely changed what was possible within
the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Waititi will be coming back for the sequel
— Thor: Love and Thunder — and based on
everything we know about the film so far,
he's going to take these heroes in even wilder
directions than before.
In addition to having the Guardians of the
Galaxy play a role, Jane Foster, played by
Natalie Portman, is returning to the superhero
franchise after being absent from Ragnarok.
This time around, though, she's not just playing
a love interest: She's donning the title of
Mighty Thor herself, and by the looks of an
exclusive behind-the-scenes photo that Looper
obtained from BACKGRID – she's taking the
part very seriously.
But preparing for her big superhero role by
never skipping arm day shouldn't come as a
surprise to anyone familiar with Portman's
career.
The Academy Award winner has always gone above
and beyond to reflect the characters she plays.
Most famously, she actually shaved her head
when her character had to do the same in V
for Vendetta, but even that pales in comparison
to what she had to do for Black Swan.
Ballerinas naturally have to be in exceptional
physical condition to dance the way they do,
and to properly showcase the art form, Portman
reportedly trained six days a week for up
to eight hours a day so that she could really
dance like a ballerina.
Her training regimen there was obviously different
from what she's doing to become Thor, but
it's clear she has the perseverance to adhere
to any workout schedule.
Even when Natalie Portman isn't necessarily
training for a role, she knows how to stay
in shape.
In a 2019 interview with Women's Health, the
megastar discussed how she keeps up her strength
even when her schedule gets hectic.
As she described it,
"I run maybe three times a week.
When I'm running for a full hour... it feels
a little like meditation to me."
Later, she discusses how she's a fan of a
style of exercise known as gyrotonics, which
essentially consists of movements you'd find
with Tai Chi, yoga, gymnastics, and other
disciplines all wrapped into one convenient
package.
Ultimately, it sounds like she keeps an open
mind and exercises in whatever manner is most
convenient in the moment, stating,
"I used to do Ashtanga, but now, I'll just
get there and I'll try anything."
Considering the results, we'd say this routine
has definitely worked well for her — and
what Portman has shared in public about her
training so far sounds brutal.
She went on The Tonight Show Starring Jimmy
Fallon to offer an update on Thor: Love and
Thunder, and while shooting hadn't started
at the time, Portman was already being put
through the wringer.
And from the sound of things, she wasn't exactly
in the best place mentally to start an intense
regimen.
She told Fallon,
"I'm trying, I've had like, months of like,
pandemic, you know, eating baked goods and,
like lying in bed, and feeling sorry for myself."
"I'm like, super tired after working out,
and during, and dreading before."
Around that same time, she also stopped by
Watch What Happens Live With Andy Cohen where
she was asked if she had to be on a workout
plan similar to her co-star Chris Hemsworth.
She said that she was, and she wasn't taking
to it very easily.
"Yes, I am training, and I'm in so much pain.
Like, I'm not good at this."
Maddy Black, formerly a Crossfit coach with
Vogue Fitness, offered some of her insight
into how Portman could accomplish such gains
in an interview with Ahlan Live.
She said,
"Natalie will be carrying out lots of compound
weightlifting movements such as squatting,
pressing and pulling.
In order to remain 'lean' for the role, she
will be implementing some high intensity interval
training into her weekly routine."
She goes on to explain how she would go about
designing an exercise regimen for someone
wanting the kind of arms Jane Foster's Thor
has in the comics, declaring,
"Weightlifting would form the foundation base
whilst functional training would develop skills,
improve flexibility and enhance endurance."
We may not know exactly how heavy her weights
are, but it's definitely clear she's been
pumping iron in one way or another.
We didn't think there was any way Portman
could look more intimidating than in her "Natalie
Raps" video, but judging from those guns,
she just proved us wrong.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.